- When people tell us
something we don't want to hear
our first reaction is they're
wrong and they're confused.
Sometimes it's hard to look
in that mirror and say,
"You know what, maybe I'm wrong."
Do you ever go online and you're
going to look up something
it's going to take three minutes.
Three hours later you're still online
you don't know why you went online
in the first place.
The Great Western disease
is I will be happy when.
When I get the money, the status, the BMW,
the condominium, when I
get this I will be happy.
- He's an American
leadership coach and author
of several management related books.
He's been recognized as one of the
top leadership thinkers in the world.
He's the author of 35 books
which have sold over two
million copies worldwide.
He's Marshall Goldsmith
and here's my take on his
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number three is my personal favorite
I make sure to stick around all
the way to the end for
some special bonus clips.
And as always if Marshall says something
that really resonates with you
leave it in the comments below
as he's saying it and put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
(gentle music)
- It's very easy to see what we don't like
about ourselves in other people.
It's a little harder to
see what we don't like
about ourselves in the mirror.
And sometimes other people
can see things in us
that we don't want to see in ourselves.
And when that happens
our first reaction is,
you're wrong, you're confused.
What people tell us something
we don't want to hear
our first reaction is, they're
wrong and they're confused.
Sometimes it's hard to
look in that mirror and say
you know what, maybe I'm wrong.
And maybe I'm confused.
What did I learn?
Sometimes other people
can see something in us
we can't see in ourselves
and our first reaction
is they're confused.
A great challenge learn
to listen to other people.
Hear what they have to say and
recognize sometimes they
can see something in us
that we don't want to see in ourselves.
We have something called the monkey mind.
Our monkey mind is our
mind is in many ways like a
monkey swinging through
the vines in the jungle.
You know thing ding ding ding
ding ding doing ding ding.
Going from this thing to thing
and the Internet provides
amphetamines for the monkey mind.
You know do you ever go
online you're going to
look up something it's
going to take three minutes.
Three hours later you're still online.
You don't know why you want
online in the first place.
Monkey mind me me me me me me me me.
It's very hard to kind
of calm down the monkey mind.
- Do you have concrete techniques
for calming the monkey mind?
- Yeah the more you measure things
the less likely you are
to have this happen.
And also the more we admit we need help
in structure.
When you get over that macho
I can do everything on my own
nonsense, life is better.
So if you know look
I'm going to go online.
Let's look at my history here.
I'm going to set the alarm clock off
so in five minutes this alarm clock
is going to go off and I'm not going
to be online anymore.
You know you might say
that sounds childish well
if you don't do it guess what?
Shhhhhhhhhhhhhh.
The Great Western disease
is I will be happy when.
When I get the money, the status, the BMW,
the condominium.
When I get this I will be happy.
Well this is the Great Western message
and it's supported by what I call
the Great Western art form.
Now what is the Great Western art form?
This is something you've seen in your life
probably hundreds of thousands
perhaps millions of times.
It's always the same story,
the story sounds like this.
There is a person.
The person is sad.
They spend money to buy
product and they become happy.
This is called a commercial.
Have you ever seen one of those before?
The message is always the same.
It's not in here, it's out there.
I will be happy when.
The reality is lottery
winners have been studied
to death and when someone wins the lottery
within three years statistically
they're not much happier
than they were to start with.
What's been learned as happiness
doesn't come from the outside.
Most of happiness comes from the inside.
Well the great employee engagement myth
is the employees will be engaged when.
When we give them this program.
When we do this process
they will be engaged when.
Well that's partially true I mean
better leaders lead to more engagement
and better recognition
leads to more engagement.
The reality is also though a lot of
employee engagement doesn't
come from the outside.
A lot of employee engagement
comes from the inside.
And one of the things that
I'm going to talk about
is how do you create an
environment where people take
responsibility for their own engagement
and instead of focusing
on I will be engaged
when the company does something
for me take responsibility
for their own engagement
and say I can engage myself.
Lying less
do more.
We spend an inordinate
amount of time in life
whining, typically whining
about decision makers.
Whining about decisions.
I'm going to talk about
five of my favorite whines
and then we'll talk about how many times
you've heard these.
And then we'll look in the mirror and say
how many times have I done it myself?
That first whine is called it's not fair.
It's not fair.
The decision maker makes
the decision we conclude
it's not fair.
Decisions have nothing
to do with fairness.
Every decision is made by the person
who has a power to make the decision.
Not a fair person, right
person or logical person.
It's made by that person.
The decision maker is the customer
and our job is to influence
the decision maker.
Not to just judge other people.
As Peter Drucker said our job in life
is to make a positive difference
not prove we're right.
Well it's not fair.
The kid comes home from school.
Daddy, mommy I got a C on my report card.
I should have gotten an A.
It's not fair.
A great learning experience for the child
decisions aren't made based on fairness.
You did not sell the teacher.
The teacher was the decision maker.
The teacher thought you
should have gotten a C.
You thought you should have laid an A.
Well you don't grade your own paper
the teacher graded the paper.
You got a C.
There's always a teacher,
there's always a boss,
there's always a customer,
there's always somebody
and it's never really fair.
Another common whine is it's not smart.
Yeah they're doing that and they think
it's fair but it's not smart.
I have a much better idea
and the world would be
better if they did it my way.
Well sometimes the world doesn't ask us
how we want to do things.
And we've got to do things that others do
and maybe their definition of smart is
a little bit different than than our
definition of smart.
And a favorite among engineers
that's related to these two is
it's not logical.
People with technical backgrounds
scientists, engineers constantly look for
logic where none exists.
And then we're shocked
because we can't find it.
Now I have a degree in
mathematical economics
I went to an engineering school so I
include myself in this category.
Too much of my life has
been wasted looking for
logic where none exists
and being shocked when I can't find it.
Well decisions are not
always made based on logic.
Oftentimes crazy people make decisions
and it's not logical.
Sometimes we say well it
they think it's logical
and there they try to
be fair it's just the
wrong decision.
They mean well, it's just not right,
it's not right.
Well again we don't get to
necessarily as we wander
through life decide what is or isn't right
in our definition of right
what might not be somebody else's.
Another big favorite is it's not their job
it's my job.
It's not their job, it's my job.
Believe it or not I see
this with a lot of CEOs
I coach.
Shockingly, I worked with a CEO
of a private equity firm.
Private equity they own the company.
I was hired by the owners.
You know what he said?
They can't tell me what to do.
It's not their job.
I'm the CEO.
Shockingly you'd be surprised
how many people become
braindead when they become CEOs.
I'm the CEO.
They can't tell me what to do.
I had to sit down and
say they own the company.
It's their money.
They can indeed tell you what to do.
You see you work for them
they do not work for you.
I had another CEO had the
same problem in a publicly
traded company with his board.
I had to sit down and say excuse me
the Board of Directors
rightly or wrongly represents
the ownership of the company.
The board does not report to you
you actually report to the board.
Now fortunately in most cases as a coach
I've been successful.
I've had a failure.
I had a failure where
a person never really
quite got it.
Now as we look at decision making
realize one thing,
our job is to make a positive difference.
Not to go through life
critiquing everybody else
with our infinite wisdom and whining.
And again some of the favorite whines
we've talked about:
it's not right, it's not fair,
it's not smart, it's not logical,
it's not their job,
we can go through life
doing this all we want to
What are we accomplishing?
Nothing.
Simple guideline for life
do more, whine less.
Take all the effort you might have spent
on whining and complaining
about other people
and focus on making a positive difference.
Try to influence those other people
don't waste so much
time judging, critiquing
and whining.
So now I'm working with my daughter Kelly.
She's a professor at the Kellogg School
at Northwestern, marketing professor.
She taught me this thing
called active questions
which I'm going to recommend
to all your viewers.
Active questions that all started with
did I do my best too?
Because that's the one thing
we have total control over,
did I do my best?
I can't blame you if I didn't do my best.
Back to accountability that's something
you can't hide from.
- Right.
- So the six I recommend every day
and there I do this daily
question process every day
these are now my first six.
Number one, did I do my
best to set clear goals?
(mumbling) did somebody
else set goals for me,
did I do my bestest at my own goals?
Two, did I do my best
to make progress toward
achieving my goals?
Number three, did I do
my best to find meaning
rather than saying, did
somebody else give me meaning
or create meaning, did I do my best
to create meaning myself?
Number four, did I do my best to be happy?
Rather than, did somebody
else make me happy,
did I do my best to make myself happy?
Then number five, did I do my best
to build positive relationships?
And then finally, did I do my best
to be fully engaged?
Every day challenge yourself
with those six questions.
Great process a great process.
And we have research on this from
thousands of people if any of the
viewers want to
participate in the research
send me an email, marshall with two L's
at marshallgoldsmith.com.
I'll sign them up for it.
Research is amazing.
46% of the people say I
got better at everything
10 days later.
75% said I got better at four out of six.
90 I think four percent said I got better
at least one.
Six percent stayed the same and zero point
something percent get worse.
It's just amazing why every
day this gets me to focus not
on what I cannot change.
It gets me to focus on what I can change.
My favorite advice
imagine you're 95.
Everyone look up here
take a deep breath and do your hand like
this go (inhales) ahhhhh.
Hand hand ahhhhh.
Imagine your 95.
And you're just getting ready to die.
And you're on that deathbed.
Here comes your last breath.
Right before you take that breath
you're given a beautiful gift.
The ability to go back in time
and talk to the person in this room.
The ability to help this
person be a better leader.
More important the ability
to help this person
have a better life.
What advice would the wise 95-year-old
you who knows what mattered in life
and what didn't have for the you
that's sitting here right now?
You don't have to say
anything or do anything,
just answer that question in your mind.
Whatever you're thinking now do that.
Terms say a performance appraisal.
That's the only one's
that's going to matter.
Some friends of mine interviewed
old folks who were dying
and asking this question,
what advice would you
have on the personal side
three themes.
Theme number one, three words,
be happy now.
Not next week, not next
year, not next month
be happy now.
Great Western disease, I'll be happy when.
When I get the money, the status, the BMW.
We all have the same when.
That old person is when.
Learning point from old
people I got so wrapped up
chasing what I did not have
I could not see what I did have
and I had everything.
People in this room many of
you are among the luckiest
humans who ever lived.
Many of you have friends
and family and health
and you're doing fun work
and you're helping people.
You got it all.
Don't get so wrapped
chasing what you don't have
you can't see it.
Learning point number
two and this is point
President Clinton made friends and family,
when you're 95-years-old
and you look around that
deathbed none of your
coworkers are waving goodbye.
You realize these people
are kind of important.
And learning point three, if
you have a dream go for it.
Because if you don't go
for it when you're 35
you may not when you're 45
and you probably won't when you're 85.
And it doesn't have to be a big one
maybe a little one.
Go to New Zealand, speak
Spanish, play a guitar.
Other people think your
dream is goofy, who cares.
It's not their dream, it's yours.
It's not their life, it's your life.
One of the greatest thinkers
in the history of leadership
development is a hero of mine, a man named
Dr. Warren Bennis.
And Warren Bennis is a wonderful guy
a guy who's helped me have a better life
and someone I've always looked up to.
Warren told the story once
I I'll always remember.
For a while he was
president of the University
of Cincinnati.
And he's not sure he
wanted to be president
for all the right reasons.
He was president and he was giving a talk
in front of a group of people
and one gentlemen raised
his hand and he said,
"Dr. Bennis, do you love what you do?
"Do you love being president?"
And Warren said he he stopped
and there was almost a minute of silence.
Eventually he looked at
this person and said,
"I don't know."
Well that moment kind
of changed his career.
He realized maybe he
wasn't being the president
for the right reasons.
Things like status, ego, feeling important
maybe those kicked in over things like
doing what I love doing and
doing what's in my heart.
Well I thought a lot about
Warren Bennis example,
do you love what you do?
In the old days if you
didn't love what you do
it wasn't so bad.
For example, in 1979 IBM
was my biggest customer.
IBM was the most admired
company in the world.
They were the God company.
In 1979 I could go to (mumbling) New York
shoot a cannon ball down
the hall at five o'clock
and hit almost nobody.
These people worked 35, 40 hours a week
and they took five weeks of real vacation.
I recently talked to the
chief Learning Officer at IBM,
I said about those same
people in that same
building now work 60 hours a week.
He said wrong, 70 hours a week.
And by the way, there's
almost no real vacation.
When you take the cell phone with you,
when you take the computer with you,
when you go on that vacation
you're constantly wired in.
There's almost no real vacation.
Very important point
for young people today.
Very important point.
If you can work 35 or 40 hours a week
and take five weeks of real vacation
and you don't love what you do,
it's not so bad,
it's not so bad.
Kind of like a half time job anyway.
If you're working 70 hours a week
and you get no weeks real vacation
and you do not love what you do
you're living in a bad
place called New Age
professional hell.
And too many people
are living there today.
Very important challenge
for people at all ages
especially young people
realize you're probably going to have
to commit to your job.
Realize you're probably going to be
working many hours.
Realize your occupation is going to be
a large part of your life.
Go back to that great question,
do you love what you do?
And to the degree you
can answer that question
yes, you're probably going to be a winner
in the game of life.
To the gray you answer that question no
you're going to have some problems.
A classic problem of
smart successful people
adding too much value
what does this mean?
I am young, smart, enthusiastic.
I report to you I come
to you with an idea.
You think it's a great idea.
Rather than saying great
idea our tendency is to say,
"That's a nice idea.
"Why don't you add this to it?"
The quality of the idea
may now go up five percent.
My commitment to its execution
may now go down 50%.
It's no longer my idea.
Incredibly hard for
smart successful people
not to constantly go
through life adding value.
Have any of you been
trained as scientists or
engineers before?
Oh this is a particularly bad disease
for this group okay.
We get so wrapped up on improving
the quality five percent
we may damage the commitment by 50%.
And by the way, most the
time we're adding too
much value what are we really doing
telling the world how smart we are.
It's incredibly hard for
smart successful people
not to constantly go through
life telling the world
how smart we are.
Does anyone in the room have a PhD?
Yes a particular disease
for people with a PhD
right yeah yeah.
Telling the world how smart we are.
I have done programs myself
called creating a great rest of your life
in this very room with the many CEOs.
My friend Alan Mulally CEO Ford has
been in this room, Mike
Duke Seal of Walmart
has been in this room.
Many many top leaders
have been in this room.
And we've talked about what are you
going to do now?
These are typically people my age
older people and 60s
maybe early 70s and talking about
what are you going to do
with the rest of your life?
And really what I've learned
is the concept of playing
crappy golf with old
men at the Country Club
while eating chicken salad sandwiches
and discussing gallbladder surgery
may not be quite as
wonderful as it sounds.
Especially if you've
had a meaningful life.
And we talk about what
is what matters in life
really what matters and waht we've come up
with a couple of things.
One is you have to be
happy at what you're doing
you have to love the process
of what you're doing.
You don't want to be a victim or a martyr.
And you also need to find meaning.
You can't just go on
cruises and play bad golf.
You have to do something
that matters in life.
And so I think it is very
important at every stage of life
we go back and look at what's important,
what matters, and what do I want to be?
We spend so little time
thinking about this.
One of my good coaching clients who was
going to retire in six months
he was a CEO of a huge company.
And I said if you knew the
company we're going to change
in six months totally
different customers, everything
would you plan for it?
He said, "Of course I would
have be a responsible person
"I'm the CEO."
"So your life is going
to change in six months
"totally change.
"Everything's going to be different.
"How much time have you
spent planning for that?"
You know what he said, "None."
Big mistake.
- Right.
- Big big mistake.
So I think it's very important as we go
through various stages of life to reflect
and think back what matters in life,
what's important?
And I don't feel any of us are too young
or old to kind of begin this process.
Creating a new identity.
How can we become someone different?
How can we create a new identity?
Now the final element of our identity
if you look at our model it's called
our created identity.
That's that new person that we can create.
That's the future that
we create for ourselves.
And in looking at this element of identity
I'm going to give you an example
from a famous rock star.
One night I had the
opportunity of having dinner
with the famous rock and roll star Bono.
And I didn't know any
of his music too much
because it was recorded after 1975.
We had a wonderful dinner though
and he talked about not his music
he talked about a lot about his identity.
And the first part of his
identity was kind of regular guy.
Not pompous or pretentious,
very much a regular person.
And you know he impressed
me as being very much
a regular guy, didn't put on airs
just seemed to be a real real person.
He used the F-word about every third word
when we were talking and he's a nice man.
He apologized he said, "You know sir,
"I probably shouldn't use
such bad language around you."
I said, "Excuse me I'm from
Valley Station, Kentucky.
"I thought the F-word was the adjective
"that preceded all nouns."
So I said, "This really
doesn't bother me that much."
Well after a regular guy
the next part of his identity
was rock and roll fan.
He's still a fan of
music and he talked about
the group's he loved and how
they influenced his life.
Then he became a musician.
And he's still a musician.
He talked about how he loved making music
and not just for money how he had
times with his family and they'd all
sing and make music together and how
much he enjoyed that.
Then he became a rock
star and he talked about
what it's like to be a rock star.
And he wasn't bragging or showing off
that's who he is, he's a rock star.
He talked about the pluses and minuses
of that life.
And now he's a humanitarian.
He is devoting a whole lot of his life
to trying to help others.
And he made an interesting point
not so easy.
Everybody didn't support him in trying
to be a humanitarian.
Some people were more into
like well who is this guy
he's shallow, he's plastic some rock star.
What's he trying to be
some kind of humanitarian?
And to his credit you know
what he said to himself?
"Forget that.
"If I want to help people I
shouldn't have to apologize
"or be ashamed of it."
And he is devoting a
huge amount of his life
right now to helping others.
Well to me God bless him.
He has created a new identity for himself
without being a hypocrite
and without being a phony.
Final point for you
challenge yourself.
Think about what is my identity now?
Second, where did that identity come from?
My memories?
Feedback from others?
Programming?
What is a new person I want to create?
How can I create a new identity,
a different person, a better person?
A person who's not the same as a
person who's there now
without being a hypocrite
without being a phony?
Creating a better me.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Jeff Davis asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next
leave in the comments below
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know what of the rules
had the biggest impact on you?
What did Marshall say that
really resonated with you?
What's the single biggest lesson that you
took from this video?
Leave it in the comments below
and I'm going to join in the discussion.
So thank you guys so much for watching.
I believe in you, I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
- The first disease of successful people
I can see a running rampant in this room
what is this problem called?
Winning too much.
Now what does that mean if it is important
we want to win.
Meaningful we want to win.
Critical we want to win.
Trivial we want to win.
Not worth it we want to win anyway.
(laughing)
We like winning.
I'm going to give you a case study that
75% of my successful clients fail.
Yes I will predict most of you will fail
this case study.
And when I say fail they fail themselves.
They say what I would do is the opposite
of what I know I should do.
Are you ready?
You want to go to dinner at restaurant X.
Your husband, wife, partner, friend or
significant other wants to go to dinner
at restaurant Y.
You have heated argument.
You go to restaurant Y.
This was not your choice.
The food tastes awful,
the service is terrible.
Option A, critique the food.
Point out our partner was wrong.
This mistake could have been avoided
if only they would have listened
to me me me me me.
Option B, shut up.
Eat the stupid food, try to enjoy it
and have a nice evening.
What would I do?
What should I do?
75% of my clients what would I do,
critique the food.
What should I do, shut up.
How many people in the room
have ever critiqued the food before?
Raise your hands food critiquers, yes
a room filled with food critiquers.
Was this a smart thing or a stupid thing?
- [Man] Stupid.
- Stupid.
(laughing)
And as stupid as it was stupid.
I'm going to give you an example now
that is so hideously stupid
it will make that one pale by comparison.
And yes I will predict
that most of you have
done this, are you ready?
You have a hard day at work a hard day.
You come home, your husband, wife, friend
or partner is there.
And the other person says, "I had such
"a hard day today, I
had such a tough day."
And we reply, "You had a hard day?
"You had a hard day?
"Do you have any idea what
I had to put up with today?
"Do you think you had a hard day?"
We are so competitive
we have to prove we are more miserable
than a person lives with us.
(laughing)
I give this example in one class the guy
in the back raised his hand.
He said, "I did that last week."
I ask him I say, "What happened?"
He said, "My wife looked at me, she said,
""Honey, you just think
you have had a hard day
"it's not over.""
(laughing)
I'd like to give you two examples
of the value of help structure
and direction.
A very positive example
and a negative example.
First, the negative.
Dr. Atul Gawande from
Harvard Medical School
wrote a great book called
The Checklist Manifesto.
In his book Dr. Gawande shares some
pretty sobering research.
If you go in for a surgery and the nurse
asks the doctor a series
of very simple questions
from a checklist before the surgery
the odds on unneeded infection plummet
and the death rate because
unnecessary infection
is dramatically reduced.
The huge majority of
hospitals around the world
do not allow the nurse to
ask the doctor the questions.
Why doesn't the doctor
want the nurse asking
them those questions from the checklist?
Ego.
The doctor is too proud to admit
they need that help.
Too proud to get that day to day
to day structure.
And they let their ego and pride become
more important than their patients.
According to Dr. Gawande
more people have died
because of the egos of surgeons
than died in the Vietnam
War, the Afghan war
and the Iraqi war combined.
What is the first question
the nurse asks the doctor?
Did you wash your hands?
Too much ego.
That's the negative case study.
Now the positive case study
every year I trained the
Admirals for nine years
in the United States Navy.
And I love working with the Navy I
I don't bill them any money
because they're billing
bureaucracy is such a
phenomenal pain in the butt.
I said we'll both make more money
if you pay me nothing, don't pay me.
They give me treats.
Afew years ago my treat
day in a nuclear submarine
me and eight other old
men got to go out on a
nuclear sub diving down under the waters
for eight hours and
pretending to torpedo things.
Ah we had a great old time.
A couple years later I
got an even better treat
where did we get to go?
Highway to the danger zone.
Have you seen that movie Top Gun?
I got to spend 95 minutes
on a United States Navy
Top Gun fighter jet.
A 6 G's oxygen flying
upside down doing tricks.
I got to fly the plane
myself for 10 minutes.
And I am very proud to
say I did not throw up.
Now before I got on the
plane I noticed something.
This kid is asking my
host Admiral Mark Watney
a series of simple
questions from a checklist.
These weren't tricky questions.
First question for the doctor,
did you wash your hands?
First question for the Admiral is,
how much fuel they have.
I said, "Sir this is puzzling.
"The doctor don't like the nurse
"she asking him the question because
"their ego iss too big."
Now I said, "No offense sir
"nobody in the world has a much bigger ego
"than a United States Navy Top Gun
"fighter jet pilot who becomes an admiral.
"You've probably got
one of the biggest egos
"in the world yet you do not object
"to this kid asking you the questions."
I said, "Sir, what's the difference?"
He said, "Marshall
there's a huge difference.
"If that operation crashes, you die.
"If that plane crashes, I die."
He said, "You put a gun to
that surgeons head and say,
""This patient dies of
an unneeded infection
"we're going to blow your brains out"
"they'd probably be asking
those questions twice."
Well how important is ego
and how important is pride?
Every day we make it more
important than our health.
than our safety, than the people we love.
Once we get over that ego and pride.
Once we get over that macho nonsense of
ahh I can do it on my own,
I don't need that checklist,
I'm above all that stuff.
Once we get over that ridiculous ego
that surgery is likely to go a lot better.
That plane flight is likely
to be more successful
and we are more likely
to become the person
in our lives that we want to become.
I'm now going to teach you a process
that takes about two minutes a day,
costs absolutely nothing.
It's going to help you get
better at almost anything.
You might be a little skeptical right now.
Two minutes a day, cost nothing,
help me get better at almost anything.
Well that sounds too good to be true.
I'm going to make a second prediction
half of the people I teach this to
you're going to quit doing
this within two weeks.
And you will not quit doing
it because it does not work.
You will quit doing it
because it does work.
You see what I'm going to teach you next
is incredibly easy to understand.
It's just incredibly difficult to do.
This is called the daily question process.
Now how does this work?
Here's what I want you to do.
I want you to get out
an Excel spreadsheet.
On one column I want you to write a list
of questions, questions that represent
what is most important in your life.
Could be friends, family, colleagues.
Every question must be
answered with a yes, a no
or a number.
A yes is recorded as a one.
A no is recorded as a zero.
Or a number, whatever that number is.
And then seven boxes across
one for every day of the
week Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
Friday Saturday Sunday.
Fill it out every day and
at the end of the week
that Excel spreadsheet will give you
a little report card.
I've been doing this for
years and let me warn you
that report card at the end of the week
might not be quite as pretty
as that corporate values plaque you got
stuck up there on the wall.
When you do this every day
you know what you learn very quickly?
Life is real easy to talk.
Life is real difficult to live.
Now I'm going to share some
of my daily questions.
Mine are not intended to be yours.
The idea of this exercise is you write
your own questions every day.
For example, what is one
of my questions every day?
How many times yesterday
did you try to prove
that you were right when
it was not worth it?
I've almost never scored
a zero in the whole life.
Kind of hard for that old professor
not to be right all the time.
How many angry or
destructive comments did you
make about people yesterday?
Well if I want to be a good person
why am I stabbing people in the back?
How many minutes did you walk?
How many pushups did you do?
How many sit-ups did you do?
Did you say or do something
nice for your wife?
nice for your son,
for your daughter, for your
son-in-law, for your grandkids?
How many minutes did you write?
Well a friend of mine Jim
Morris has been doing this for
years and when he began doing it one of
his daily questions was,
are you currently updated on
your physical examination?
The first 90 days he did this he said
no every day for 90 days.
No no no.
After 90 days he said this is embarrassing
it's embarrassing I got
to get the dumb exam
or quit asking a question,
it's embarrassing.
He got the dumb exam.
What did the doctor say?
"You have cancer."
Now he's going to be fine,
that was many years ago.
The doctor also said, "Had
you waited seven more months
"you would be dead."
He knew he should have
got a physical exam.
He's not a stupid man.
Chief Learning Officer
of three multi-billion
dollar companies.
He knew he should have done
it, but he didn't do it.
In my classes I ask people,
"How many of you have put off
"getting a physical exam
before and told yourself,
""I'm getting that exam after I go on my
"healthy foods diet.
"I'm getting that exam after
I begin my exercise program.""
Pretty much half the
class raises their hand.
And then I say, "Did you really trick
"the doctor with that strategy?"
Well I was teaching at
the University of Michigan
this guy raised his hand, I said,
"Sir, did you trick the
doctor with that strategy?"
He looked at me, he
goes, "I am the doctor."
Well why don't we ask these questions?
We're afraid of the answers.
If you have the courage
to write down the behavior
that's most important in your life
and the discipline to do this every day
you're going to get a lot better.
Now I pay a woman named
Kate to call me on the
phone every day, she called me today.
She's going to call me tomorrow.
She called me yesterday.
She calls me every day.
Every day she listens to
me read these questions
that I wrote and provide the answers
that I wrote every day.
Now someone asked me,
"Why do you pay a woman
"to call you on the phone every day?
"Don't you know the theory about
"how to change behavior?"
"I wrote the theory about
how to change behavior.
"That's why I pay a woman
to call me every day."
I know how hard this is.
I have over 12 million
frequent flier miles
just on American Airlines.
That's an excuse to be a bad father,
a bad husband, out of shape.
How many excuses do I get
with the 12 million miles?
Many excuses.
Excuses don't help.
It's hard for me, it's hard for you,
it's hard for all of us.
Why do I pay a woman named Kate
to call me on the phone every day?
Just to listen to me
read questions I wrote
and provide answers I wrote>
My name is Marshall Goldsmith
and the world's top-ranked
executive coach.
I am too cowardly to do this on my own
and too undisciplined
to do this on my own.
Why do I pay someone to call me
on the phone every day?
My name is Marshall Goldsmith
I need help and it's okay.
Now let me help you.
Next step's get out
that Excel spreadsheet.
Write down those questions.
Every day test yourself.
If you have the courage
and discipline to do
this on your own every day
knock yourself out, do it.
If you notice that you're quitting,
you make excuses like ahh
I got too busy, didn't have time.
It takes two minutes a day.
You weren't too busy.
I got bored.
You didn't get bored.
Why did you quit?
It's hard to face the reality
of our own lives every day.
If you have the courage
and discipline to do this
by yourself, do it.
If you do not have the
courage and discipline
to do this by yourself,
which most of us don't, like me,
get somebody else to help you.
And get over that shame
and pride thing and say,
"Hey I need help."
It's okay.
If you try this you're going to find out
it will help you get better
at just about anything.
And it doesn't take a lot of time
it just takes a lot of courage